et
[Musique]
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
delphine batho bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous est en porte
parole de yannick jadot le candidat
écologiste à cette élection
présidentielle
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et de ouest-france bonjour
stéphane bonjour on est belle film et on
commence en parlant de l'ukraine
évidemment l'armée russe n'avance plus
l'armée ukrainienne annoncent avoir
repris la ville d'hier pin's et dans la
banlieue de kiev mais dans le même temps
les ministres russes de wagner
pourraient être déployés dans l'est du
pays et mario paul est dans une
situation humanitaire jugée
catastrophique emmanuel macron et de la
dîmière poutine doivent s'entretenir sur
une opération humanitaire est ce que
emmanuel macron est le seul aujourd'hui
à permettre une issue diplomatique à ce
conflit
c'est à dire est ce que c'est le seul à
pouvoir parler à vladimir poutine on a
vu les tensions ce week-end entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine la manière
dont joe biden a qualifié vladimir
poutine on sait que yannick jadot est
plutôt critique sur la manière dont l
emmanuel macron s'adresse à vladimir
poutine mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui n'est
pas la solution à ce conflit le chef de
l'état vous savez je crois je crois pas
au sauveur dans cette dans cette guerre
le président de la république française
est actuellement le président du conseil
de l'union européenne
donc c'est normal qu'il fasse son
travail et nous avons besoin d'une
mobilisation de l'union européenne mais
surtout ce dont nous avons besoin moi je
suis pour toutes les opérations
humanitaires la situation à marioupol
est catastrophique elle est dramatique
sur le plan sur le plan des droits
humains sur le plan des victimes donc
tout ce qui peut être fait doit être
fait mais la vraie question politique
qui est posée c'est celle d'une nouvelle
étape des sanctions européennes et de
frapper poutine sur le nerf de la guerre
c'est à dire sur l'argent des énergies
fossiles et c'est la raison pour
laquelle yannick jadot 2 depuis déjà
plusieurs plusieurs semaines qu'il faut
décidé un embargo sur les énergies
fossiles russe c'est à dire sur le
pétrole et sur le gaz de poutine qui
actuellement finance cette guerre pour
environ 700 millions de dollars par jour
donc c'est ça la vraie question
politique qui est posée dans le rapport
de forces est une critique vous le dites
si yannick jadot est élu président de la
république est ce qu'il dira au
chancelier allemand sur cette question
tant pis on y va bien et maria membres
de l'union européenne qui sont sur cette
position je vous le signale et il y as
parmi les états membres de l'union
européenne qui sont sur cette position
des états membres qui dépendent beaucoup
plus même plus que l'allemagne du gaz de
poutine que la france donc oui il y à il
ya une discussion européenne à avoir
mais on est dans un moment de
basculement historique tout le monde
comprend bien en fait avec la tragédie
actuelle ce qui est en jeu la question
c'est que l'union européenne est la
première importatrice mondiale d'énergie
fossile ça veut dire que nous nous
depuis des décennies les écologistes ont
toujours dit nous nous lions les mains à
l'égard de puissance qui disposent de
ces énergies fossiles aujourd'hui un
dictateur vladimir poutine mais ça peut
être les pétromonarchies la solution
pour l'europe n'est pas de se tourner
vers une autre dépendance en
l'occurrence celle du gaz de schiste
américain qui en termes dans plus d'un
pacte écologique est une catastrophe la
vraie solution c'est d'organiser la
transition énergétique de sortir de ces
énergies fossiles donc ça c'est la
réponse de long terme mais dans
l'immédiat il ya des sanctions à prendre
parce que la la cette idée si vous
voulez que il faut garder ça pour plus
tard qu'on est trop dépendant qu'on va
continuer à importer du gaz de poutine
jusqu'en 2027 c'est pas raisonnable et
ça n'adresse pas en fait à poutine et à
l'oligarchie russes les bons signaux par
rapport à la nécessité d'obtenir tout de
suite un cessez le feu et le maintien de
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine et
de sa souveraineté certes mais est ce
qu'on est capable de fermer les robinets
d'un coup d'un seul les pays de l'union
européenne ont déclaré qu'ils avaient
l'intention de se passer du gaz et du
pétrole russes à horizon 2023 6027 2027
pardon sap a été actée ou sap a été
écrit très précisément lors du sommet de
versailles quelle serait la bonne
position est ce que c'est possible de
sortir du gaz russe très rapidement
comme vous le suggérez c'est possible
comment alors d'abord nous avons
actuellement des réserves donc ça c'est
la première chose c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas jusqu'à l'hiver prochain il n'y
a pas si vous voulez de je sais pas
comment dire ça de black out par rapport
de gaz mais cher c'est le cycle hiver
prochain c'est après choisi à une vraie
question pour l'hiver prochain donc sur
l'hiver prochain il ya la question de
l'être l'acheteur unique européen c'est
ce que nous demandions par rapport à ce
qui a toujours été la position française
jeu que j'ai conduite moi en tant que
ministre qui était la stratégie de la
diversité d'approvisionnement pour ne
jamais être dans la situation de
dépendre à plus de 20% de tel ou tel
fournisseur donc ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième c'est qu'en fait ce
qui manque dans tout ce qui est dit
aujourd'hui c'est le fait d'investir
massivement dans les alternatives
l'année dernière on a encore installés
en france 715 un décalage on en a un à
celle d'un vaisseau de se développer de
nouvelles filières pour arriver à
composer aujourd'hui un effort de guerre
d'économie de guerre dans
l'investissement dans les économies
d'énergie et dans le changement des
chaudières
catalyseur un accélérateur c'est qu'en
fait c'est une urgence sociale absolue
regardez les avant même la guerre en
ukraine regardez les factures de
chauffage de cet hiver regarder le
nombre de personnes qui ne se chauffent
pas ou qui ne saute chauffe plus ou qui
ne chauffe qu'une pièce fût elle donc en
fait cette situation elle est à la fois
une dépendance géostratégique par
rapport à un dictateur mais elle est
aussi une question d'urgence sociale de
réduire les dépenses contraintes des
ménages est en fait dans tout ce qui est
dit aujourd'hui sur ce volet là il ya
quasiment rien ou presque on était quand
même dans une situation pour qu'on se
comprenne ou au mois de janvier l'union
européenne a inscrit le gaz comme dans
ce qu'on appelle la taxonomie
c'est-à-dire l'a reconnu comme énergies
vertes comme énergie de de transition
question ces aberrations c'est
complètement insensé où jusqu'à
récemment l'un
l'installation de chaudières à
condensation chez les gens bénéficiaient
de ma prime rénove c'est à dire
bénéficiant d'une donc en fait on a mis
en place des systèmes dette d'état pour
mettre les gens dans une dépendance nous
les écologistes nous voulons faire
linverse nous voulons de
l'investissement public massif pour
sortir les gens de là des messages aux
énergies c'est du long terme cette
transition est ce qu à court et moyen
terme la seule solution d'indépendance
au gel c'est mal et moyen terme à court
et moyen terme personne n'a dit qu'il
fallait sortir du nucléaire demande à
qui ça va booster votre calendrier de
sortie du nucléaire nous nous gardons le
projet de yannick jadot ne ferme pas de
réacteurs nucléaires dans le prochain
quinquennat mais permettait quand même
une remarque c'est que s'il est question
aujourd'hui ce qu'a dit la ministre de
de l'ecologie barbara pompiers hier qui
est une aberration de rouvrir dirt
continuer à faire fonctionner une
centrale à charbon en france c'est
là une partie du parc nucléaire qui est
à l'arrêt pour des raisons de
maintenance et pour des raisons de
sûreté et donc on joue on a la
démonstration que la trop grande
dépendance de la france au nucléaire
pour son électricité c'est aussi une
vulnérabilité est donc le retard qui a
été pris puisque la france est le seul
pays de l'union européenne à ne pas
avoir tenu ses objectifs en matière
d'énergies renouvelables le retard qu'a
été pris en matière d'énergies
renouvelables on le paye cash
aujourd'hui en termes d'augmentation des
prix et avec cette idée folle de
remettre de reporter la fermeture d'une
centrale ges que les difficultés d'edf
sur le parc nucléaire elles sont pas
liées aussi à une politique écologiste
qui est bonne plus investir sur la un
pardon les difficultés d'edf sur le parc
nucléaire je vais vous dire à quoi elles
sont liées elles sont liées en partie
est en très grande partie au changement
de statut d'edf qui a été transformée en
société anonyme ce qui a conduit pendant
des années à ne pas investir parce que
les actionnaires privés même
minoritaires ont voulu leur dividende
parce que l'état actionnaire lui même a
voulu ses dividendes et que donc les
investissements de maintenance qui était
indispensable dans les centrales
nucléaires n'ont pas été faits pendant
dix ans c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui yannick jadot propose de re
nationaliser complètement edf parce que
il y a besoin d'investir les réacteurs
en fonctionnement doivent être sûrs et
par ailleurs il faut surtout investir
massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables et cécile ce qui permettra
le moment venu de diminuer
progressivement la part du nucléaire
sans jamais mettre en danger la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de la vallée de la
première préoccupation des français
stéphane c'est le pouvoir d'achat oui à
partir de vendredi sur une remise de 15
à 2 818 centimes par par l'idée sans
sera appliquée sur l'ensemble du
territoire est ce que le gouvernement a
raison de prendre cette mesure est ce
qu'il est suffisante ce qu'ont proposé
d'autres choses alors elle est tardive
cette mesure elle est insuffisante et
c'est une mesure électorale en fait mis
en oeuvre le 1er avril sous forme d'une
remise qui n'est pas une vraie baisse
des taxes donc en fait tout le monde
comprend que c'est temporaire avec un
risque que ce soit temporaire pour les
élections et puis que plus tard là où se
reprennent donc la situation elle elle
était en plus sale et indifférenciée
socialement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que quelqu'un qui a un niveau de
revenus extrêmement confortable avec un
énorme véhicules qui consomment beaucoup
va être proportionnellement beaucoup
plus aidées par l'état que
l'assistante sociale ou l'aide à
domicile des deux sèvres qui va chez les
personnes âgées avec sa clio et et qui
proportionnellement si vous voulez
consommera mais pour le son pouvoir
d'achat ça représente pas du tout la
même chose il ya un autre système le ce
que nous disons depuis des mois et des
semaines c'est qu'il faut un chèque
énergie à 400 euros pour tous les tous
les ménages les plus exposés à la hausse
des prix des carburants versées de façon
automatique et un chèque de 100 euros
pour les catégories jérôme gaza sera
perçue par qui tous les ménages exposé
ça veut dire que ça concerne pied et à
quelle fréquence les mais il ya 6
millions de ménages
6,5 millions de ménages les plus
modestes et 15 millions de français qui
sont exposés aujourd'hui à la hausse des
coûts de l'énergie et là aussi sur la
question des transports pardon mais il
faut là aussi
travaillé aux alternatives parce qu'en
fait tendanciellement en fait tout le
monde j'ai été très frappé on auditionné
bruno le maire à l'assemblée nationale
il disait en gros l'inflation est
temporaire le choc actuel et le choc est
temporaire ça me paraît très imprudent
en fait de dire ça et ça me paraît très
imprudent de considérer que le choc sur
le prix des énergies fossiles il est
temporaire au regard des enjeux
climatiques mais aussi au jeu regard de
la raréfaction des ressources en
énergies fossiles et de leurs coûts qui
augmentent toujours donc clairement dans
un autre monde ensuite on est en train
de basculer dans un autre monde
malheureusement qui confirme beaucoup
des alertes des écologistes est donc en
fait la question sur les déplacements
aussi c'est de développer le covoiturage
c'est de mettre en place là où c'est
possible les transports en commun c'est
d'aider les artisans et un certain
nombre d'automobilistes à faire ce qu'on
appelle le retrofit c'est-à-dire à
garder leur voiture actuelle et à
changer le moteur pour transformer leur
véhicule en véhicules électriques
alors qu'on a en plus une filière
industrielle française qui sait qui sait
le faire c'est toutes ces questions qui
sont posées en ville le vélo on a en
fait un certain nombre de solutions qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas déployées et en
particulier permettez moi d'insister sur
le covoiturage puisque on a même des
entreprises françaises qui me proposent
des systèmes les territoires ruraux moi
je suis d'un territoire rural dans les
deux sèvres des systèmes de tous les
trajets ne sont pas qu'aux voitures à
bhl excusez-moi l'expression mais
beaucoup des trajets quotidiens pour se
rendre au travail le sont et on a des
systèmes extrêmement extrêmement
performant qui rendent gratuit pour le
passager et qui donne un avantage à
l'automobiliste qui va co voiturer
d'autres personnes dans sa voiture
pourquoi on est pas les territoires à
faire ça en fait l'autre question
évidemment il ya la hausse des prix de
l'énergie mais aussi la hausse des prix
alimentaires puisque la guerre en
ukraine il a entraîné une hausse des
prix alimentaires est ce que yannick
jadot proposera un chèque alimentaire
sur l'alimentation il ya une chose que
je voudrais rappeler
c'est que les prix du blé qui flambe
actuellement on commençait de flamber à
l'automne dernier pourquoi parce qu'on a
eu le dôme de chaleur au canada la
sécheresse sur tout le continent nord
américain la sécheresse au kazakhstan et
que donc on a eu des pertes de
production en céréales et en blé
extrêmement importante qui ont contribué
déjà à une augmentation historique des
prix à l'automne dernier donc en fait
cette idée que qui est celle de monsieur
de normandie le ministre de
l'agriculture que pour faire face au
risque d'une crise d'insécurité
alimentaire mondiale dramatique suite à
la guerre en ukraine ce serait de s'en
[__] de l'écologie de 100 foot du
réchauffement climatique de remettre en
cause les jachères les deux y aller sur
encore plus d'engrais encore plus de
pesticides c'est une folie parce qu'en
fait ce qui menace la sécurité
alimentaire mondiale c'est la guerre
bien sûr mais c'est aussi le changement
climatique et l'effondrement de la
biodiversité quand par exemple on a en
france 85% d'insectes et de
pollinisateurs en moins sur un certain
nombre de cultures on a des rendements
par exemple du colza ou du tournesol qui
diminue parce qu'il ya plus de
pollinisateurs donc on est dans une
aberration totale mais si on est dans un
dans une pénurie qui risque d'arriver à
farc nos agriculteurs fasse manger les
français est ce que là c'est pas la
meilleure défense du modèle dit
optimiste attendez il n'y a pas de
risque de pénurie pour la france le
problème pour la france
et nous allons avec yannick jadot tout à
l'heure en bretagne le problème pour la
france c'est de reprendre son
indépendance
or l'agriculture française aujourd'hui
elle dépend des engrais qui viennent
d'ukraine elle dépend du soja qui est en
train de liquider de contribuer à
liquider la forêt amazonienne donc nous
avons besoin de revenir à un modèle
français vertueux de polyculture-élevage
d'une alimentation de qualité et qui
permet aux agricultrices et aux
agriculteurs de vivre de leur travail
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas et
qu'on a tous les jours des suicides
d'agricultrices et d'agriculteurs ce qui
est inscrit et un drame terrible en fait
donc nous note orient tation à l'éclair
c'est l'agroécologie une alimentation
saine et de qualité accessible pour tous
et une un travail des agricultrices et
des agriculteurs qui leur permet d'être
rémunérés et de vivre correctement par
rapport à la sécurité alimentaire
internationale puisque c'est ça aussi la
dimension de la question de ce que nous
demandons c'est la libération des stocks
c'est à dire qu'il ya aujourd'hui à
l'échelle mondiale de façon privée ou de
façon publique un certain nombre de
stocks de céréales qui doivent être
libérés par un grand dossier manuel
mâcon par rapport aux pays qui en ont
qui en ont besoin un mot sur un thème
qui est arrivé dans la campagne c'est le
rapport sénatorial sur les cabinets de
conseil oui les noms ce recours au
cabinet de conseil recours trop élevé on
parle de près d'un milliard rien que
pour 2021 ce que yannick jadot président
de la république mettra fin au recours
aux cabines et primé totalement
complètement plus au quart d'heure je
voudrais rendre hommage au travail
parlementaire
parce que cette commission d' enquête
sénatoriale
a fait un travail remarquable et voyez
c'est utile quand même d'avoir un
parlement qui n'est pas aux ordres du
gouvernement et de l'exécutif
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième c'est qu'en fait on est sur un
démantèlement de l'état vous savez
j'avais été renvoyé du ministère de
l'écologie pour avoir dénoncé le mauvais
budget de l'écologie ce ministère il a
perdu 15 mille agents
en un certain nombre d'années et en fait
les gouvernements successifs ils ont
fait la révision générale des politiques
publiques la modernisation de l'action
publique là maintenant ça s'appelle ap
2000 actions publiques 2022 c'est une
logique en fait de liquidation des
compétences et des savoir-faire de
l'état et après on vient payer beaucoup
plus cher de façon mais honteuse
scandaleuse des cabinets de conseil qui
font un boulot mais nulle en plus il
faut le il faut le il faut le dire donc
c'est une situation scandaleuse est ce
que nous proposons au delà même de la
question de ces cabinets de consultants
ce que porte yannick jadot c'est une loi
de séparation des lobbys et de l'état
parce qu'il faut mettre fin à la
collusion entre un certain nombre
d'intérêts privés et l'exercice des
responsabilités du ministre deux fois
une fois un mois une fois un nom en gros
vous n'avez jamais eu recours à des
cabinets conseils quand vous étiez
ministre n'ont aucun jamais en tout cas
l'arrivée mckinsey non et je n'ai pas
commandés
d'études de ce genre là que lorsque j'ai
été lorsque j'ai été ministre c'est
vraiment une dérive nouvelle pour vous
non c'est une dérive qui a commencé son
les précédents gouvernements elle a pris
avec emmanuel macron une autre ampleur
elle a atteint un paroxysme
parce que c'est devenu en fait c'est
devenu un réflexe une habitude dans tous
les domaines sur tous les sujets de
faire appel dans des conditions qui sont
invraisemblables un cabinet pardon mais
qui paye même pas ses impôts en france
en plus de ces une forme
d'externalisation si vous voulez de la
puissance publique au profit d'intérêts
privés parce qu'en plus ces cabinets ils
ont d'autres clients donc il ya des
questions déontologiques extrêmement
lourde en fait qu'ils sont qui sont
posées dans cette question je voyais que
même la commission européenne est aussi
dans ce type de stratégie et appel après
on nous parle de souveraineté européenne
non on a en fait en france des
fonctionnaires compétentes et compétents
on doit élever le niveau d' expertise de
l'état et donc en fait c'est l'héritage
si vous voulez de 30 ans discours sur
abba les fonctionnaires l'état coûte
trop cher etc etc qui amène à ce type de
dérive extrêmement grave
est-ce que vous en êtes de la compagnie
yannick jadot qu'est ce que vous pensez
qu'il va réussir à faire au premier tour
et est ce que pourquoi est ce que les
choses ne décolle pas ou pas plus je je
je sens mois que les écologistes peuvent
être la surprise de cette élection dit
peu surpris à quel point la surprise en
termes de performances du résultat je le
souhaite je le souhaite et
j'appelle à une très grande prudence à
l'égard du matraquage des sondages
d'opinion dans cette campagne
présidentielle je pense qu'on a atteint
un record il y en a plusieurs chaque
jour
qui lui reste il aurait stress
qui peut faire la science appliquée si
vous permettez deux choses la première
c'est que c'est sondages ils ont une
difficulté récurrente et sans porter de
jugement sur sur le travail qui est fait
par les instituts de sondages ils ont un
problème récurrent d'estimations du vote
écologiste à toutes les élections
récentes avec des écarts extrêmement
important entre le résultat dans les
urnes et ce qui était dans les sondages
avant le résultat du scrutin d écart de
8 points 10 points et c'est donc c'est
considérable ça a été rejeté les
européennes en 2010 aux régionales aussi
par exemple en auvergne rhône-alpes le
sondage 10 et 11 on a fait 14,5 pardon
mais c'est pas la même chose donc ça
c'est après un show la deuxième c'est
qu'on ait vous là vous l'avez bien
notées
dans une élection extrêmement où il ya
une très grande volatilité
je ne sais pas on ne sait pas quel va
être le taux de participation est donc
on peut être dans une situation où il ya
des différences énormes c'est très
ouverte possible c'est le jeu est très
ouvert et moi ce que je sais c'est que
la conscience écologique elle a beaucoup
progressé dans la société française et
que de plus en plus de françaises et de
français savent que les solutions pour
le pouvoir de vivre pour réduire les
dépenses contraintes les solutions aussi
pour la jeunesse pour nos enfants
passent par le fait qu'on prenne en
compte les enjeux de l'urgence
climatique de l'urgence pour la
biodiversité de l'urgence pour le vivant
et que cette force en fait d'espérance
elle va se traduire par un bulletin de
vote qui est un bulletin de vote dont on
est certain de l'efficacité immédiate
parce que le score corps à l'écologie
politique dans cette élection il sera
déterminant pour ce qui va se passer
ensuite en fait pour la façon dont ces
enjeux s'imposeront au gouvernement nous
souhaitons être en situation d'accéder
au deuxième tour mais vraiment moi mon
message c'est celui-là à toutes celles
et tous ceux qui nous écoutent venez
voter et ne vous laissez pas entraîner
dans une espèce de conditionnement qui
vise à vous faire croire que cette
élection présidentielle est déjà joué
que c'est même pas la peine de se
déplacer c'est faux et une forme de vote
utile ségolène royal notamment à les
appeler au vote utile en faveur de
jean-luc mélenchon et elle dit
d'ailleurs qu'il a fait un bond dans les
sondages depuis son intervention qu'est
ce que vous en pensez pour moi ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas du tout un vote utile
parce qu'on est dans un moment
historique où la question des valeurs en
fait est une est une question absolument
fondamental et vous savez il ya beaucoup
de candidates et de candidats depuis un
mois qu'on me un petit peu de un petit
peu de vert dans l'eure dans leur
programme et jean luc mélenchon
notamment 1 il n'est pas le seul
prétendait avoir pris en compte les
enjeux écologiques premières questions
concrètes le maintien de total en russie
bah il est pour le maintien de total en
russie il est pour le maintien de la
dépendance dans le contexte de la guerre
en ukraine de la france et de l'europe
aux énergies fossiles importées de 50 à
celle inverse d'un choix écologistes en
fait de la même façon qu'il a moqué ce
que propose yannick jadot sur les
questions que vous posiez tout à l'heure
par rapport à notre dépendance au gaz
russe
il a moqué les propositions qui disent
qu'on doit investir dans les économies
d'énergie et qu'on doit faire ce qu'on
appelle aussi de la sobriété c'est à
dire que celles et ceux qui actuellement
ne se prive pas de chauffage parce
qu'ils en ont les moyens c'est pas trop
leur demander de baisser la température
d'un degré d' 1 5 degré j'ai moi même
des collectivités locales dans les deux
sèvres qui ont décidé de baisser partout
la température de 1,5 degré parce que
c'est un choix économique rationnel et
parce que c'est aussi le fait de se dire
notre société peut être mobilisée elle
peut faire un effort en solidarité avec
la résistance yanick nadeau dimanche au
zénith dit on ne vote pas pour ceux qui
refusent d'appeler un dictateur un
dictateur est ce que claire millares
jean luc mélenchon est disqualifié pour
exercer cette fonction présidentielle ce
que je dis c'est qu'il faut voter pour
yannick jadot est ce que je dis c'est
qu'il y a des différences majeures
entre
jean luc mélenchon et les positions
qu'il prend sur les énergies fossiles
sur poutine sur le fait de refuser de le
qualifier de dictateur et la position
qui est celle des écologistes vous avez
parlé de ce qui va se passer ensuite
après la présidentielle pour gouverner
il ya aussi le rendez-vous des
législatives est ce que vous pouvez
est-ce que la gauche peut y aller la
gauche les écologistes peut y aller 18
comme la présidentielle s'il faut faire
les accords avec à chaque scrutin en son
temps
chaque scrutin législatif sans accord
les élections législatives dépendent
d'abord du résultat de l'élection
présidentielle je le regrette puisque je
suis pour un parlement souverain et je
suis pour un régime institutionnel très
différent de celui dans lequel nous
sommes mais la première bataille c'est
celle de l'élection président et vous
viendrez nous en parler entre elles
avaient essentiels et les sept îles
merci delphine batho de l'avoir était
notre invité par parole de yannick jadot
le candidat écologiste la une d'ouest
france et la guerre autour de poutine
qui sont les responsables c'est la
question à la une de ouest france merci
beaucoup
[Musique]